[Musique]
joyeux Noël à tous les habitants de
Gotham flash spécial Gotham vient de
recevoir le titre de la ville la plus de
la planète alors que notre cher Batman
continue de faire le ménage ah je suis
prêt à devenir un vrai super-héros comme
toi
ouvre-le et Joy Noël ma propre bat de
ceinture qui ne doit être utilisé qu'en
cas de Bat urgence ça va papa je suis
plus un bébé j'ai jamais dit que tu
étais un bébé alerte alerte appelez les
secours mon bébé est en
danger c'est la Justice
League désolé Damian il faut que j'y
aille dois supposer que vous n'avez pas
vu le batasoir je l'adore cette barbe
elle augmente mon capital intimidation
il y a des morceaux de baignet dans
votre capitale
intimidation je te promets d'être de
retour avant
Noël oh non je suis le pire papa du
monde
[Musique]
Jer je réveillon de Noël so
V me de
faireantl jeis prver à PAP que je
peuxbrouiller tout
se pas grandose celui laissecune place à
l'imagination papa fait un B
costume
trop
bien ah et en plus il s'adapte
automatiquement tout simplement parce
qu'il faut pour être un superhér laisseo
faire je vais sauver
no d'accord lequel d'entre vous lui a
refilé des
explosifs il est temps de briser la
glace petit
Batman et maintenant fait quoi tu veux
être mon bras droit
dis plutôt ton pied droit
[Musique]
capable